قدمت الولايات المتحدة مركبة برادلي للمشاة القتالية
بمفردها تقريبًا لوقف
هجوم روسي بالقرب من إيفا في
جنوب شرق أوكرانيا، ورشقت
الروس بقذائف التتبع من
مدفعها القوي عيار 25 ملم، وتم
تثبيت قوات فلاديمير بوتين غير قادرة على التقدم،
وهذا مجرد عنصر واحد من
جهود أوكرانيا للحفاظ على إيفا.  هربنا من
مراكز القيادة تحت الأرض في
مواقع سرية، لقد منحنا الأوكرانيون إمكانية
الوصول إلى مخبأ قيادتهم لهذا
الجزء من الخط الأمامي ومن هنا
نظموا جزءًا من الدفاع عن آيفا،
نادرًا ما يكون الأمر هادئًا هنا كما يقولون إن
الروس يهاجمون
روسيًا طوال الوقت تقريبًا  تظهر دبابة مع مجموعة صغيرة من
القوات الأوكرانيون يتتبعون
تحركاتهم وهذان الجنديان
ربما من وحدة مدمرة بالفعل
يختبئان في خندق يدركان أن
الأوكرانيين اكتشفوهما، فضربوا
الروس
بطائرة كاماكازي بدون طيار لكنهم نجوا في الوقت الحالي،
يقول القائد  لي الخسائر الروسية هنا
مذهلة إنهم يستخدمون الكثير من المعدات
ونحن ندمر الكثير من المعدات ويقول إن
الكثير من هجمات المشاة ينفقون
الناس وهم يدوسون على بعضهم البعض ولا
يقدمون المساعدة، صحيح أن هناك
الكثير من معدات المشاة واعتداءات اللحوم
من  من خلال العديد من الطائرات بدون طيار التي تراقب
ساحة المعركة، نرى جثث
الجنود الروس القتلى متجمدة وسط مركباتهم
المدمرة،
كما يوجه مركز القيادة
ضربات المدفعية والصواريخ وحتى الهجمات المضادة بالقوات البرية
لتطهير الخنادق ووقف
الموجات التي لا نهاية لها على ما يبدو من
هجمات المشاة الروسية، ولحسن الحظ أنهم  يقول إن لديهم الكثير من
الخسائر، لكنهم لم يتوقفوا ولكن
إيفا ستكون لنا، ولن ينجحوا،
لكن البنادق المقدمة من الولايات المتحدة إلى أوكرانيا
يمكن أن تصمت في الغالب قريبًا إذا
لم ينهي الكونجرس مأزقه ويمرر
مساعدات عسكرية إضافية. يقول الرئيس بايدن
أعتقد أن  الغالبية العظمى من
أعضاء الكونجرس يؤيدون المساعدات المقدمة
لأوكرانيا، والسؤال هو ما إذا كانت
أقلية صغيرة ستوقف
هذه المساعدات أم لا، وقد يكون ذلك كارثة وقد
يكون له آثار كبيرة على
القوات الأوكرانية التي تقاتل هنا.